the assassination of haiti's president
jevenelle moise has drawn international
condemnation
haiti has declared a two-week state of
emergency following the deadly attack on
the president
giving the executive branch stronger
powers to deal with what appears to be a
worsening situation in the country
president moise was gunned down by
unknown assailants at his home
near the capitol port-au-prince
overnight haiti has seen a rise in
politically motivated violence
in recent months
this was the moment giovanna muis knew
he had won haiti's presidential
elections in 2015. he was officially
sworn in
over a year later with his wife martin
moyes
by his side
his rule came to a sudden end when
gunmen raided his home
in the early hours of wednesday his wife
was critically wounded
streets in puerto pas have emptied out
following the assassination
the international airport was closed
the government has declared an emergency
declared we have decided to declare
a state of siege in the country
i share the sorrow of the president's
wife
who happened to be with him the evening
of the attack
assassination comes amid rising gang
violence and a growing humanitarian
crisis
food and fuel shortages as well as
rising inflation are making life
extremely difficult for haitians
over half the population earns less than
two dollars a day
and the political situation has been far
from stable
for the past two years moist had been
ruling haiti
by decree after the country failed to
hold elections
a result of political gridlock and
unrest
opposition leaders have been demanding
moyes step
down they claim his term legally ended
in february 2021 following the
assassination
international leaders warned of an
escalation
this is a critical moment i think we all
knew it was sensitive and difficult
on the ground in haiti in view of the
political situation and the security
situation
this puts that in even greater danger
than before
on twitter the eu's top diplomat joseph
burrell
wrote shocked by the assassination of
haitian president jovenel moyes
we had an exchange at a diplomatic forum
only three weeks ago
this crime poses a risk of instability
and a spiral of violence
the perpetrators of this assassination
must be found
and brought to justice so far
no group has claimed responsibility the
attackers and their motives
remain unknown
well for more now i'm joined by pierre
richard middy he's a freelance
journalist from
haiti pierre it's good to have you on
the program
you and your family fled haiti due to
death threats against you because of
your work
as a journalist let me ask you the
forces that were behind those death
threats
are they connected to the violence that
is obviously connected to the
assassination of the president
thank you very much for inviting me to
to speak
with you about the situation in haiti
connected to the
assassination of the president of haiti
a twist to answer your question uh
i used to cover uh corruption
uh and uh political uh events in haiti
and
uh i start receiving tweets
because the
the people uh close to the national
palace to the government
they started to tell me that uh because
of my reports
the government has some trouble i am the
one
which uh uh don't help them to make
their rocks uh to i
i like that i okay you you you
because of your work the country is
going bad we can do more
so i had to leave the country because
they promised me that they
they were going to kill me and uh it's
not exactly connected to the gangs
in haiti but it was much closer to the
asian government
and i had to flee because uh it was very
important to take uh
the streets very seriously because a
asian journalist
has been killed all the time and uh
nothing happened after that
let me ask you did you see though this
assassination coming because of this
the violence in the country did you
think that this type of
an attempt to take someone's life was
very likely
no never i'm gonna be honest with you
it's unbelievable
it's unreal because uh okay i id is a
very
violent country is a dangerous country
people
are killing every day every time but
imagining that the president
could be killed assassinated at his uh
red dance it's unreal so
this is to tell you um i'm shocked
i'm still shocked by uh
for what what's happening to today in my
country uh
it's a very difficult to believe because
uh
the president should be the one the
people a
a with the most uh a improvement a
protection but it's not that's that's
the way to tell
to the world to show to the world that
haiti is a a very
dangerous country and everything can be
happening in that country
i'm very um i feel my heart
burning let me ask you what we're
hearing we're hearing that
the the president said that his term
had not ended yet but members of the
opposition were saying
that it ended a year ago and that they
couldn't reach an agreement on that
um which is it's hard to believe that
could be the reason for this
assassination but do you see a
connection there
no i i because you know a
opposition the government they they
never
it's a very a tough situation they never
would like to to stay and speak together
to try to find a way to resolve the
the asian crisis but uh i can't believe
and i don't believe that i think they
there could be a very deep investigation
to know exactly
why the asian president has been killed
has been assassinated i
i don't believe i don't trust that there
are some kind of connection
between okay
but we will we will find out and we'll
wait to see too if there will be an
investigation journalist pierre richard
joining us tonight it's pierre we
appreciate your time and your insights
thank you
you